now is that time of year where we're
swapping out our winter clothes for
warmer weather what are your style
predictions for this summer well there
is one Trend that has dominated both the
runway and the red carpet and honestly
social media and that is skin is in
whether it's cutouts or a lot of sheer
panels you are really seeing women
Embrace their skin today is the first
day of spring and to help us get ready
we teamed up with lifestyle expert
Liliana Vazquez and Jurgen skin care to
celebrate their first ever glow day glow
day is so much fun this is all about
prepping your wardrobe and your skin for
sunnier moments ahead so it's that
transition time where you want to take
stock in your closet your skin um your
confidence
I brought our gorgeous models to help me
illustrate the hottest Trends right now
color and cutouts so we're saying
goodbye to those Moody tones from Winter
and you know I rely on jurgen's Natural
Glow daily moisturizer for my clients to
provide a beautiful sunless tan that is
the perfect complement to these fresh
pastels for spring color check now you
mentioned cutouts so first you're going
to want to start by applying Jergens
Natural Glow daily moisturizer as your
daily moisturizer use it for about a
week and you're gonna have a beautiful
natural looking tan
so these rib cage cutouts here I'm gonna
have you spin around to the back of the
open back cut out it's really without
getting that skin glowing and to feel
really confident in the skin that you're
in
[Music]